there is more and more control from the government
and here is the state secretary
indeed responsible for
so I now address the State Secretary
about the way people live their lives
since January 1 and January 1
extra tax is given on sugar
the same applies to alcohol and tobacco products
the government is increasingly interfering with what
people may and may not consume
for democracy
she is convinced that people
be best able to live their own lives
to lead
I just said the party of the good life
not from the forbidden and you
can't do it all
if people want to smoke 1 cigarette
Want to drink 1 coke or 1 cocktail at home
want to make let them
it is completely
not the task of the government to deal with that
keep busy
and certainly not to earn even more money from it
if we still have 1 healthy lifestyle
want to stimulate
then let that happen through
that is our proposal
burden reduction
instead of discouraging and burdening
of behavior that,
according to the state,
would be unhealthy
what would, for example,
be the question of the State Secretary
so be the effect
of abolishing the tax on
sports subscriptions
I would like to hear from the State Secretary
how he would like to stimulate healthy lifestyles
by means of tax relief